[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
o
[Musica]
beh sarà uno degli ultimi lavori che ho
realizzato quest'anno allo sferisterio
immaginata io mi occupo di video mapping
dal 2010 ma ping è una tecnica che ci
permette di disegnare con la luce su
superfici di vario genere quello che
faccio in realtà a creare un video
sull'architettura che poi viene ri
progettato su l'architettura stessa
mediante grandi proiettori per
realizzare un dito parto sempre dalla
musica ceram that che diceva che
l'architettura la musica congelata io mi
ritrovo molto in questo pensiero in
quanto una musica ogni facciata una
musica se secondo me una volta
individuata la musica attraverso la
musica attraverso gli effetti della
computer graphic
il mio intento è quello di tirare fuori
l'arma milioni architettura essendo
stato uno dei primi in italia fa a
portare questa tecnica questo è l'uomo
di ascoli a pietro ma ho avuto la
fortuna di viaggiare molto e lavorare
moltissimo nel 2013 sono stato invitato
al festival di mosca con festival un
concorso internazionale a cui sono
arrivato terzo
e lì è stato il momento in cui il
compito che una passione questa mia
passione poteva essere trasformata in un
lavoro vero e quindi sono andato anch'io
continuarlo a illuminare diverse piazze
uomini chiese un po ovunque fino
arrivare nel 2017 al al palazzo
d'inverno di san pietroburgo
gli ho fatto un lavoro per i 100 anni
della rivoluzione russa a oggi sono
veramente molti lavori che ho fatto che
ricordo con più piacere è quello di
trieste in piazza unità d'italia nel
e questo il pd
[Musica]
ma no
grazie
c'è stato poi un periodo che mi sono
fortemente appassionato a van gogh alla
sua vita i suoi dipinti
leggendo della sua storia è rimasto
colpito che dopo aver realizzato la
camera ad arles era rimasto
insoddisfatto in quanto quello per lui
era un periodo positivo e lo stava
vivendo in attesa di gauguin che lo
raggiungesse ad arles quindi periodo
pieno entusiasmo mentre questo quadro
dava una
forte sensazione di angoscia e questa
sensazione angoscia era data al fatto
che sul palo erano ammesse tutte le
ombre così che è sempre con la tecnica
del sito ma ping ho pensato di ricalcare
questa volta che un edificio un quadro è
una volta ottenuto il 3d del quadro
mi abbassato mettere una luce per
ottenere tutte le ombre reali la cosa
più difficile è stata seguire le
prospettive di van gogh e che erano
volutamente sbagliate mentre con il
computer partiamo da una prospettiva
perfetta però una volta costruiti tutti
gli elementi poi le ombre avevano il
giusto posto diciamo ho fatto questo
lavoro sia sulla camera che su altri
quadri solo per esperimento poi alla
fine sempre da dove mancavano le ombre
poi alla fine ho messo insieme tutti
tutte le sedute i dipinti che aveva
illuminato a cui avevo messo le ombre ha
dato una piccola animazione ho messo il
video su youtube delle a poco è
diventato virale sono stato invitato ai
grandi magazzini sui iuris a londra per
inaugurare una nuova televisione oled
con il video e poi è stato il punk rock
musivo a chiamarmi per portare il mio
video un mese al pan noti museum di
amsterdam
i risvolti sono stati moltissime
nonostante abbia fatto questa cosa per
pura curiosità e questo è il video sopra
gogh
[Musica]
[Applauso]